so with the recent events that have
happened over the last few chapters i've
noticed the series seems to be hitting
down an extremely dangerous path with
the characters that we the readers deem
us safe be now in utter danger due to
the constant escalation of conflict and
the obvious increase in age this means
to gain money through these gangs that
are now turning into organizations more
like the yakuza is turning the entire
story upside down and makes it honestly
fearless though takamichi has no
possible way of fixing mikey's future
without putting the lives of his friends
and loved ones at jeopardy which was
something that he swore he wouldn't do
at the beginning of the final arc so in
this video i plan to expose what i think
the entire outcome of the tokyo
revenge's story will be and how
takamichi will certainly achieve this
obviously this is just a prediction or
theory of mine and i don't know if this
is actually going to happen for sure but
in this video i want to explain why i
think takamichi will actually fail in
this timeline due to what's happened in
the most recent chapter along with how
he is going to fix this entire situation
which will involve the revival of the
currently dead people throughout the
story with the help of kazutora hanemiya
who like harma has always been someone
that seems to show up randomly just when
you're about to forget all about him
this will involve something i'm going to
call the last jump as i believe on this
last jump takamichi will say goodbye to
everyone in a figurative sense while
saving shinichirosano's life and a young
kazatora from darkness but anyway just
before we get into the video if you are
new around here and want to keep up to
date with the latest tokyo avengers
content and just other anime videos in
general then be sure to hit that
subscribe button and also be sure to
leave a like on the video as it really
helps out with the algorithm and pushes
my stuff to a bunch of new amazing
people but anyway enough of that let's
get into the video
so i guess i'm going to start off and
explain to you guys why i think
takamichi is going to fail in this
specific timeline and mainly that is
because i think we're going to start off
here and now see the deaths of probably
a majority or a a lot of original timing
members and older thoma members that
that have been with us throughout the
entire arc so far although takamichi
isn't obviously wanting to get them
involved it's going to be completely out
of his control as he's kind of built up
this aura around his name obviously and
so do the other thomann members all the
father people obviously know them as
strong people throughout the delinquent
world and they're going to want to kill
them or you know defeat them and they
fight so that they can move up
themselves and that doesn't just you
know stick for takametsu drak and that
sticks for pretty much every single
family member and uh i guess division
captain or vice captain of the tokyo
manji gang as they are all formidable
forces in the delinquent world so i see
a bunch of them being snuck up on like
takamichi has and possibly being you
know killed here so like obviously in
the future timeline draken was
originally alive but if draken dies here
then this can affect the future and the
way that possibly takamichi decides to
go back to the past and live out his
life because he say doesn't want the
other toma numbers attacked or he feels
like he's completely failed and kind of
crawls back into a hole and becomes that
shallow of a person as he was before
and so kazotora obviously is someone
that i brought up at the beginning of
the video and i think he's the key to
the entire story here he's a founding
member of tomen and he's kind of the one
that has started mikey's spiral into
darkness he's kind of been the reason
that two of the people that mikey's love
the most have been the ones that have
passed away not exactly the reason that
bhaji passed away but he was a big you
know uh a big force towards baji's death
so as we know in every timeline so far
that we have seen kazatura in the future
he's randomly showing up and kind of
been around takamichi or got takamichi
to the side and then they've both i
guess tried to save mikey as he and each
timeline hasn't believed that this is
the future that mikey's wanted or he's
been manipulated into it so i think in
this final timeline with this last jump
that i've been talking about there's
possibly two ways that this last jump
with kazatora which is what i'm hinting
towards could happen because obviously
we know that kazutura wants to change
the future and fix everything that has
happened with maki and so does takamichi
there's an obvious goal between them and
we know that from the past for two
people to be able to travel back in time
or for takamishi to be able to travel
back in time through someone they need
to be able to have a mutual agreement
with each other and so the first thought
that i kind of have or the idea on how
takamichi could possibly convince
kazutora while he's currently in the
past here without actually traveling
back to the future because that would
involve having to meet mikey and then
shake mikey's hand which is a huge you
know what if obviously is if takamichi
decided to go to the juvenile center
that kazatura is currently at and meet
talk with him because as we know
kazakhstan kind of left on a somewhat
good note saying that he wanted to take
responsibility for bhaji's death and as
i was saying in the future timelines
kazutori has always been there wanting
to save mikey and this arc is all about
wanting to save mikey so i believe that
possibly takamichi could go to the
juvenile where kazatura is at and try
and convince him into and i'm not sure
if this is even possible traveling back
while they're in the past kind of like
an inception type travel where it's you
know like dream within a dream they're
jumping within a jump in a kind of way
and i don't exactly know if this is
possible as we don't have any
confirmation if it is possible or not
whether you can jump while you're in the
past obviously takamichi is able to
reveal to people that he has this time
this time leaping ability while he's in
the past and it won't affect the future
too much so can he let kazatura know
this and tell him everything that
happens and the possible outcome so that
he can convince kazatura into jumping
back and trying to stop kazutura from
originally killing shanachiro which was
the beginning of it all if shinichiro
isn't dead then none of this actually
happens apart from possibly kisaki but
will get to kisaki in a
the other way that i see this possible
situation taking place is that takamichi
kind of formally gives up after
mikey finds out about this you know dark
news and i guess before he's completely
indulged into his dark impulses and goes
i guess on a killing spree and decides
to kill all the other time members
because as we know once he finds out
that one's dead or once he kills one it
never really ends there for mikey he
kind of indulges into it and continues
down that dark path or even if maiki
does get to the point where he wants to
try and i guess hurt the other toman
members and takamichi for some reason
decides to gather them in an original
tournament and he's the leader type
thing and they all break out into a to a
big fight or we could just have the the
three gangs going at each other with the
roku harder brahman and kanto gangs
going at each other we could just have
those three fights going and the
possibility of somehow i'm not even sure
how it would happen exactly but
takamichi manages to shake mikey's hand
or get a hold of mikey's hand throughout
this fight it could be accidentally or
on purpose i'm not sure like obviously
how it would happen it would have to be
completely up to ken how we would do the
scene or how he would do the moment
exactly something else that i wanted to
bring up as well that i don't think has
anything really to do with my theory in
general
but it could have possibly helped with
takamichi's ability and it evolving
actually over time and the fact that it
could evolve even more as when we first
you know get the kazatora versus bhaji
fight in chapter 55 because of her stabs
bhaji otaku means she actually didn't
see that angle but for some reason the
panel that we get that shows us that
khazitora is stabbing bhaji in the back
of him it's kind of this the shaded gray
color compared to the entire chapter
which is the normal dark pen style and
then say when you look at the takamichi
and kisaki fight and when he gets that
premonition or that future sight of when
kisaki asks hina to marry him it's a
slightly different panel style with some
like time style lines going in the
background but it's quite shaded and
it's got its own different look to it
and then now when takamichi is getting
his future sites and the later chapters
like 2 19 and 2 i think it was 16
originally they gave us more of the
normal type box but more of a shaded
style again and that kind of jagged type
style that we also got from the heiner
and kisaki flashback so
has possibly takamichi's ability evolved
over time and we're going to see another
evolution throughout the up-and-coming
arc at some point it could just be a
thought i don't actually think that's
the case i just wanted to point that out
at some point so i thought i'd chuck it
in here
something though that uh could kind of
go against takamichi and this theory
that i do want to point out is the
complete age difference i'm not sure on
the date exactly but i'm pretty sure it
would make takamichi 11 years old so
would an older kazutoro you know even
believe takamichi in the first place
when he comes back to the past and tries
to stop him from robbing um the garage
it wouldn't be hard to stop them if you
could just point out that it's
shinachiro's garage or even get
shinachiro just to turn the lights on in
the entire place or something like that
it wouldn't be too hard for him to kind
of put a warning signal up just to have
the entire situation not go ahead so
there's not this massive
misunderstanding and then sadly like the
death of shinochiro as if taking me
she's able to stop there then mikey
still has this brotherly or fatherly
figure that he can look up to that is
exactly like takamichi you know someone
that he almost does look up to in
another way and i think it would be also
quite interesting if he did go back we
might also get to see what shinochiro
sana was like and if he was exactly like
takamichi and we get to see how their
personalities are quite similar and
things that maybe they got up to with
the black dragons back in the day i'm
not sure if they were still around
around this specific time period if
takamichi would travel back to when
shinichiro got murdered i'm not sure if
the black dragons or the first
generation black dragons would still be
around or not but it would be extremely
interesting if they were being able to
see you know what kind of person he was
like and how he like ruled them being
someone like mikey i would say but then
being like takamachi at the exact same
time another thing that i do want to
point out that could possibly go against
this theory as well as the thought of
equal exchange so obviously in the
series so far for pretty much every life
that takamichi has saved there's been a
life that has been taken from us so like
takami shi saved kazatura he didn't get
mikey to kill kasaturo but instead baji
still ends up dying which is the sad
case there and so on and so on
throughout the entire story
so obviously there's that factor of
equal exchange but actually even is
there because we know that baji still
died in the original timeline so
the factor of equal exchange it could be
there for sure but i'm not a hundred
percent on the idea of equal exchange at
the moment until maybe we get some kind
of hint that takami she figures these
things out later down the line as at the
moment i kind of just think that this is
mikey's ever-evolving darkness that has
gotten worse and worse with every death
that he's had throughout his family so
far and then finally with dragon here
that's been the final catalyst for it
all sitting him over the edge completely
not being able to be saved unless
everything you know is rewritten from
the start and like obviously you'll be
thinking how is this going to i guess
result in a good outcome because
obviously there are a few things going
against takamichi and this like the fact
that kisaki is also still alive so any
of those people that have been in the
comments section really quickly typing
you know what about kisaki kisaki the
time leaper blah blah well kisaki would
still definitely be alive in this
timeline but would he pose a massive
threat like he would definitely still
pose a massive threat towards hina and
takamichi would know that for sure
obviously going into this but i'm
wondering at what time in his life
takamichi originally showed up and
stopped the bullies they were fighting
the cat i wonder if it was around the
same time that kasatura happened to kill
shinichirosan which you know was at the
exact same time that kisaki first grew
as hatred for takamichi because of
takamichi stepping in and saving hina
and from that moment on she loved
takamichi etc etc so maybe if there's
some kind of change there and some
possibility
it could change the entire kisaki
development throughout the entire story
and we could see a different person
possibly in the future and on the entire
side of mikey and his manipulation and
trying to become the one who rules i
guess all of japan through the
delinquent world well i don't know how
he would do that when bhaji kind of
picked up on him in the first place and
baji would be there with kazutora the
only reason that it kind of fell
to pieces to start with was because
kazatura had left the original game
because he believed that he needed to
kill mikey and all this other you know
complete and utter garbage that had kind
of manifested while he was in juvenile
while he was completely stewing on his
thoughts so i would imagine it's
completely different now that all of
them all of the five founders are still
alive and still in a tokyo manju gang
together with no one being dead i'd
imagine that it's probably a completely
different dynamic
and like obviously because from the time
that shinichiro originally did die there
was two years of that development that
mikey also wouldn't have had so will
shinochetto possibly still being around
if this is the
outcome that does happen and takamichi
somehow ends up travelling back with
kazutor at saving shinichiro then mikey
would probably be a lot more of a
developed person with a personality
probably a lot more like takamichi and
he'd be able to see you know his brother
grow up and which would in turn mould
mikey in the correct way so that he
wouldn't grow up enveloping these dark
impulses because of the the darkness
that he's constantly holding in
throughout the deaths that are happening
throughout the series as there wouldn't
be any so there would be no need for
this envelopment of darkness to build up
inside him was shinichito still being
alive and with emma still being alive
and with dracon's still being alive it
would kind of fix everything or at least
more or less that's kind of like how i
see it at the moment obviously there's
probably still more things that i've
missed and other people probably like
you know but like what about hina and
takamichi will take shanhina be together
then because if takamichi goes back to
normal then his life is just going to
end up with him working you know at the
dvd store just being an employee not the
manager like he is in one timeline which
definitely could happen but this is the
takamichi that has stuck with us for at
this point i would imagine over
260 odd chapters maybe 270 and he is not
the exact same person at the start of
the series anymore he learned extremely
early on you know not to back down and
cower out from his fights and like naoto
says on their last handshake that they
have at the start of the tenjiku arc he
says that no matter how many times he
fails he would constantly go back to
nayoto so i feel like takamichi knowing
that everything would be fixed would
have the courage to just walk and meet
hina as the 26 year old adult that he
actually is or more or less that's kind
of how i think things would play out
because i i believe he'd be able to go
back and just made her and maybe she
doesn't have those feelings for him
anymore but he would have the courage to
probably be able to build them with her
by that point anyway i'd love to know
what you guys all think down in the
comment section below this video was
just like a lot of my thoughts kind of
spewed out onto paper on what i was
thinking about the series in general and
how kazutori still has a large part to
play in it as he's always been there in
the future timelines wanting to save
mikey as he was i guess an original
cause to what's happened in the first
place but yeah as i was saying be sure
to check a comment down below and if you
guys are new around here i want to keep
up to date with latest tokyo avengers
content and more i guess just anime
content in general then make sure you
hit that subscribe button and also be
sure to leave a like on the video as it
really helps out with the algorithm and
pushes my stuff to a bunch of new
amazing people
but anyway enough of that for now it's
been your professional degenerate dear
follow and i'll see you all any bit
bye